Design is a very common cognitive activity. Some people even claim that
design is a single cognitive activity that has the most economic value of all
such activities. Configuration is a type of routine design,
that occurs every single day. For example, you need to run some errands.
You know the roads, you know the vehicle, you know the traffic patterns.
Now you need to configure the specific route that can optimize some
constraint such as time. Cooking is another everyday example of configuration.
We know the recipes, which tell us about the high level plans and
the ingredients we need to assign values to specific variables that can optimize
some constraints such as taste. Notice that we can separate task from method.
Configuration is a task that can be addressed by many methods. We will look as
several of them, such as [UNKNOWN]. Plant refinement, [UNKNOWN] test, and so on.
[BLANK_AUDIO]